[موسيقى]
في غرفه صغيره يسكن محمد وعائلته مع
والديه وسط بيت لا تتجاوز مساحته 100 متر
ويشغل غرف البيت الاخرى اخوانه وعائلاته
ما يجعل الحياه في البيت خانقه ومحرجه
دائما ان مشاكل على طول مشاكل انا واخوي
لانه خصنص باب عقبال باب بيته غرفه عقبال
غرفته بالضبط ودائما مشاكل من ورا الصغار
ومشاكل وضغط يعني الواحد الله يعينه براوه
من الشغل تعبان ومش قادر مش حمل مشاكل
وبرجع بلاقي مشاكل الصبح مشاكل وفي الليل
مشاكل برضو هذا كله انا ما ليش ذنب فيه
يعني كتير وزاره الاسكان يعني عدد سكان
كثير احنا ايش ذنبنا احنا
[موسيقى]
يحصل محمد على قوت يومه من بسطه متواضعه
لصنع القهوه والذره على شاطئ بحر غزه وهو
دائم البحث عن منزل اخر اكبر ولكن ازمه
السكن وارتفاع الاسعار وضيق الحال تجعل
بحثه بلا جدوى عدد سكان البيت اكثر من 15
نفر مع الصغار
اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد
وضع الاقتصادي صعب مش قادرين نعمل فيها اي
حاجه حتى انه مش قادر احط نايل فوق حتى
اعلق المطر انه يخش جوا على البيت